- On est vraiment dans
les travaux d'impression
des bulletins de vote.
- Plus que quelques jours
vote par anticipation.
Des centaines de milliers
d'électeurs exerceront
leur droit de vote
les 25 et 26 septembre.
Élections Québec veut
accommoder, comme lors de chaque
élection, le plus grand nombre
de Québécois. En 2018, près
d'un million d'électeurs avaient
voté avant le jour du scrutin.
JULIE ST-ARNAUD DROLET, dir.
générale des élections du Québec
- On se déplace aussi
au domicile des électeurs
es de se déplacer
pour des raisons de santé.
- En revanche, lors de la
dernière élection, deux millions
de Québécois inscrits sur
la listela listela listela lists
voté. Certains par désintérêt;
d'autres en raison
d'un contretemps.
- Attention, s'il vous plaît..À,
de nombreux voyageurs
se préparent à quitter le pays.
- On part trop tôt pour le vote
par anticipation et on revient
trop tard pour les élections.
- Plusieurs d'entre eux, comme
ce fils et sa mère, auraient
souhaité voter par la poste
depuis l'étranger. Mais ils ont
dû abandonner l'idée, en raison
de la complexité des procédures.
- Je pensais que ça allait être
plus simple, genre, une lettre
par la poste ou quelque chose
comme ça, mais non, c'est...
c'est vraiment compliqué.
- Un peu déçu, parce que ça va
être la première fois dans
ma vie que je manque mon vot
- Seulement 3500 électeurs
se sont inscrits au vote
hors Québec cette année.
Parmi eux, ce camionneur longue
distance qui travaille
surtout aux États-Unis.
FRÉDÉRIC BISSON, camionneur
- J'ai toujours voté à toutes
les élections, alors là,
je m'attendais à soit
facile, comme au fédéral
la dernière fois, j'étais
à Vancouver, alors j'ai pu voter
par la poste.
- Frédérraconte avoir
fait des pieds et des mains
pour recevoir sa trousse de vote
par la poste.
- La plupart de mes collègues,
juste dit : "Bien moi,
je ne voterai pas, c'est bien
trop compliqué, ça n'a pas
de bon sens."
- Rien pour faciliter l'accèsaue
en pleine saison de chasse.
- Les chasseurs sont nombreux
à nous poser des questions
à savoir comment faire pour
voter alors qu'on est absent
pendant les jours de vote.
CHARLES PINARD, président, Ass.
des pourvoiries de la Côte-Nord
- C'est sûr que si un chasseur
part pour un mois, bien là, il a
un choix à faire dans la vie.
Est-ce qu'il veut voter,
se prévaloir de son droit de
vote, ou il veut aller chasser?
- Élections Québec veut rendre
le vote accessible à tous.
C'est pourquoi, en plus du vote
par anticipation, cinq journées
de vote supplémentaires
sont prévues entre
le 23 et le 29 septembre au
bureau du directeur du scrutin.
Ici Hadi Hassin,
Radio-C